je
on en est où les clients potentiels qui
pourraient me suivre j'ai arrangé un
rendez vous très prometteur quelle est
l'entreprise laconia g dirige la colère
owen jasper crise d'hyper 26 fait quoi à
s'inviter pêche j'ai dit à saqba sac à
main un truc pour respirer devrait
préciser tout cas il est trop beau jeu
c'est une vente privée
celle à cognac d'arrivée laissez moi
vous présenter notre directrice des
relations publiques en fait tu sous la
table j'ai fait tomber des documents
qu'ils te rappelles lowell celui qui
voulait que tu laisses tomber sa
carrière il a il a beaucoup de succès
aujourd'hui m'a croisé au one here ça il
est reçu craquer sûrement owen jasper
avec ton assistante quoi de mieux pour
moi puis de tirer un trait sur mon amour
de jeunesse en regardant tomber amoureux
quelqu'un d'autre mon directeur
financier va arriver wren tu peut
l'accueillir vestiaire a ravi de vous
rencontrer
habib moi aussi quelqu'un ressenti les
ont qui intriguera comment on fait pour
savoir quand tourner la page tu
t'adresses à la mauvaise personne c'est
pas toujours évident de tourner la page
de toute évidence il a toujours des
sentiments pour toi tu es là tu
morfondre alors que tu devrait décider
si oui ou non ce gars est assez bien
pour toi je vais y arriver non
oui ça va aller elle bouge bien son
corps on dirait qu'elle a fait ça toute
sa vie
oh
dis-moi qui n'est pas trop tard
[Musique]